here's where I'm at the reason I brought
out inverse trig is because I've got
theater as the subject and I want to
work out the theater on the yard
directly okay
now by the way even though you're like
of course derivative in verse three and
number one you still need to know your
derivatives of all the inverse trig
functions when you do that topic right
so you can't avoid it and secondly as
you see when these results come out
there are actually some ways in which
it's kind of kind of neat ah then when
we young took the reciprocal and had all
these trig functions in our derivative
okay so let's have a go let's just think
of the basic case when you've got cos
inverse of X okay what's the derivative
what does it look like cos inverse is
the one that's dropping down so it's
like this okay so that tells you the
sign of the derivative will be neither
it will be negative right so it's minus
something okay
now this point you you're sort of need
to just use your memory okay so it's one
over the square root of does anyone
remember what comes in because I'm just
using X just regular X it's one minus X
square
okay I was so close okay and of course
when you're doing sine inverse it's just
positive okay anyway so if that's my
derivative for just cos inverse of X
here you've got the careful okay because
not only is it a mystery it's also chain
rule okay so you've got three over R in
there I'm going to differentiate that
and then I'm going to need to know the
derivative of three on earth what's the
derivative of 3 on our this is three out
of the power of minus one right so it's
minus 3 on our squid okay I'm just
putting that on the side so that there's
less in my brain when I'm actually doing
chain rule okay so now I think that's
enough let's let's give this a go
okay our differentiate the outside which
looks like this okay so I've got minus 1
over the square root of 1 minus now it's
not x squared is it because then I have
an X I've got 3 over R okay
it's going to be mine over R squared to
get that it's three over R or squared so
there's my intuitive of the outside now
I plug in the derivative of the inside
which is just that other way okay all
right so I can tidy up just a little bit
I can put battles three now this point I
suppose I could put this into the into
the underneath the square root
it'll be the square root of R to the 4
but I'm not gonna bother to be honest
because I'm better now you may delete
something anyway it's not dramatically
simpler so I'm gonna go R square 1 minus
so there's the third on the are I can
sub that in here now right so I know a
dr/dt is it's just minus two so if I
multiply that by - - I'll get minus 6 R
squared
- okay by the way just compare this to
what you had before when we got to the
MDT the theta on D - sorry okay
what was it you were like cause theaters
and sign theatres why is this look so
different so drastically different it's
the same teeth in order to why is it
different
how can one derivative the same
derivative we calculate in one way and
we get treat function there and we
calculate another way and there are no
tree functions how's that work
thank you this stiff you don't it takes
same derivative but it's all in terms of
hours it's in terms of a length okay you
don't do treat ratios on lengths okay
but before a derivative was in terms of
theta so that's why we had causes in
science there's my derivative I don't
want the general I want to add a certain
point namely as we worked at before
where are 's equal to 5 so when I was
equal to 5 defeat on the T is okay by
the way you see this is why some people
would like to use con your inverse tree
naturally because I don't have to go
back and forth between what are and
what's theta I just plug my numbers
straight in sorry that's just 25 times 5
this 5 and that to this 4 becomes 2 and
this 6 becomes 3 is it looking familiar
it's minus 3 over 10 radians okay so in
terms of broad numbers of lines they're
pretty close actually I think I mean
they occupy about the same amount of
space on the board
I'm the trickiest part I think is just
remembering what the derivative of your
invest 3 functions are if you do that
and you don't mess up your chain rule
it comes out not too badly okay so you
can use inverse trig for these questions
wherever you've got angles involved
you've got both choices okay unless they
say to you use in verse 3 and then you
have to do